see when when we heard those explosions
we thought there could be any other
explanation but a terrorist attack we
haven't had that confirmed by the
authorities here but certainly by the
way that they are responding and the
advice we have been given to leave hand
luggage that kind of stuff that would
suggest that they are also treating this
as a terrorist attack although again I
should stress that hasn't been confirmed
at all now there seems to be a number of
coaches out here on the airport we've
moved out the building now sarah-jane
we're just moving past Rose des plaines
which of course have been grounded as a
result of this and people up here be
getting on buses to see if I can have a
word with a few people at the moment did
you hear what happened did you hear what
happens when you saw was a bomb you see
will you close to it at the time are you
close you near Scylla one okay okay I
think this one thinks there were four
explosions I only heard two I think that
other people think there are only two
explosions as well but they they are
there's no doubt in those people
people's minds that it was a bomb and
which case of course a terrorist attack
here at Brussels Airport in the heart of
Europe the capital of your